♪ ♪
>> Juan: DEMOCRATS NOW
BATTLING EACH OTHER OVER GUN
CONTROL.
BETO O'ROURKE , LEADING A DIVIDE
AFTER SAYING THAT HE WANTS TO
TAKE AWAY ASSAULT WEAPONS.
BUT MAYOR PETE BUTTIGIEG,
AGREEING THAT BETO O'ROURKE 'S
COMMENTS GAVE THE RIGHT WING
AMMUNITION TO ATTACK.
>> RIGHT NOW, WE HAVE AN AMAZING
MOMENT ON OUR HANDS.
WE HAVE AN AGREEMENT AMONG THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE FOR NOT JUST
UNIVERSAL BACKGROUND CHECKS, BUT
WE HAVE A MAJORITY IN FAVOR OF
RED FLAG LAWS, MAGAZINES,
BANDING THE NEW SALE OF ASSAULT
WEAPONS, WHEN EVEN THIS
PRESIDENT, AND EVEN
MITCH McCONNELL ARE AT LEAST
PRETENDING TO BE OPEN TO
REFORMS.
WE KNOW THAT WE HAVE A MOMENT ON
OUR HANDS.
>> Juan: BETO O'ROURKE FIRING
BACK AT BUTTIGIEG FOR SAYING
THAT SENATOR MITCH McCONNELL
MAY BE INTERESTED IN GUN REFORM.
SAYING "[BLEEP], THAT IS NOT
ENOUGH.
IT IS A LIFE OR DEATH ISSUE."
DANA, TO MY EARS, IT SOUNDS LIKE
THEY WANT FOR     FEWER GUNS ONH
THEY WANT FOR     FEWER GUNS ONE
STREET AND THEY WANT FEWER
MURDERS.
HOW DO YOU HEAR IT?
>> Dana: OKAY, BUT ONE OF THEM
SAID THAT PEOPLE WOULD LITERALLY
GO AND TAKE PEOPLE'S GUNS FROM
THEM.
A MANDATORY BUYBACK.
THE MANDATORY PART IS, I THINK,
WHAT EVERYBODY, RIGHT.
IT'S NOT AN ASSAULT WEAPON.
THEY DON'T DEFINE IT.
I THINK WHAT BUTTIGIEG IS SAYING
THAT YOU, BETO O'ROURKE  ARE
PUSHING US SO FAR TO THE LEFT
THAT WE CAN'T POSSIBLY WIN IN
2020.
>> Juan: DEMOCRATS LOVE THIS
STRAIGHT TALK, YOU KNOW?
THE NRA'S ALWAYS WINNING THE
ARGUMENT THAT THEY SAY, EXTREME,
YOU KNOW, THEY ARE GOING TO COME
AND TAKE OUR GUNS.
YOU HEAR A DEMOCRAT STAND UP AND
SPEAK DIRECTLY TO THE ISSUE.
SO IS THIS A MESSAGING FIGHT OR
IS IT SOMETHING BIGGER?
>> Jesse: I DON'T KNOW WHAT
KIND OF PEOPLE YOU WANT TO THE
BALL GAME WITH, JUAN, BUT I
DON'T THINK PEOPLE ARE VERY
HAPPY WITH IT, EVEN BUTTIGIEG.
DEMOCRATS HAVE ALWAYS WANTED TO
TAKE YOUR GUNS.
BETO O'ROURKE  IS THE ONE STUPID
ENOUGH TO SAY IT.
YOU GUYS HAVE ALREADY WANTED TO
CHIP AWAY AT THE SECOND
AMENDMENT AND BETO O'ROURKE
CAME ALONG WITH A CHAINSAW AND
SAID LET'S GO.
AND NOW, THEY DON'T TRUST
DEMOCRATS.
THEY DIDN'T TRUST THEM VERY MUCH
TO BEGIN WITH.
IF YOU LOOK AT ALL OF THE ISSUES
THAT THE DEMOCRATS ARE RUNNING
ON GLOBAL WARMING, TAXES, GUNS,
IMMIGRATION, THEY'VE LOST THEIR
PATIENTS, AND THEY DON'T WANT
INCREMENTAL CHANGE ANYMORE.
THEY WANT TO OPEN BORDERS,
SOCIALISM, RAISE TAXES, GRAB
YOUR GUNS.
THAT SCARY STUFF.
BETO O'ROURKE  IS A MANCHILD.
I HONESTLY BELIEVE THAT HE WAS
SERIOUSLY AND GENUINELY AFFECTED
BY THE MASS SHOOTING.
BUT NOW HE HAS SHRUNK HIS
CANDIDACY DOWN TO A SINGLE ISSUE
THAT WILL NEVER GROW UP INTO
ANYTHING NATIONALLY, AND HE'S
BEEN WRONG ON THIS ISSUE FROM
THE VERY BEGINNING, BECAUSE IF
YOU LOOK AT IT, I HAVE A LIST OF
ALL OF THE LATEST MASS SHOOTINGS
HERE, I THINK, AND     , AND ALL
HERE, I THINK, AND     , AND ALT
HERE, I THINK, AND     , AND ALE
HERE, I THINK, AND     , AND ALL
HERE, I THINK, AND     , AND ALS
HERE, I THINK, AND     , AND ALT
SIX YEARS.
90% OF THEM PASSED BACKGROUND
CHECKS.
THE ONES WHO DIDN'T, THE KID
STOLE IT FROM THEIR MOM OR DAD.
IT'S NOT ABOUT THE RIFLE, WHICH
IS LEGAL.
IT'S ABOUT SOMETHING OTHER THAN
WHAT THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT.
>> Juan: OKAY, SO, GREG, I
THINK WE HAVE A SITUATION WHERE
AMERICANS ARE VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT MASS MURDERS AND PEOPLE
BEING SHOT.
I THINK THIS IS A BIG ISSUE.
FROM ANOTHER PERSPECTIVE, AND,
JESSE, IF YOU COULD SAY,
BETO O'ROURKE IS NOW TALKING AND
HARSH, EXTREME TERMS ABOUT
ASSAULT WEAPONS.
HE IS FORCING PRESIDENT TRUMP
AND DEMOCRATS TO DO SOMETHING IN
THE MIDDLE.
>> Greg: HE VALIDATED
EVERYTHING THE NRA SAID WOULD
HAPPEN, AND HE'S DONE MORE
DAMAGE FOR REAL CHANGE WHEN IT
COMES TO LIMITING ACCESS OF GUNS
TO THE UNSTABLE.
I CAN NO LONGER TRUST THE
CONCEPT OF RED FLAGS AS SOMEBODY
WHO BASICALLY INTRODUCE IT HERE
TWO OR THREE YEARS AGO.
BETO'S SHOWED ME HOW THE
RED FLAG GIMMICK WOULD BE
CALLOUSLY ABUSED IN TARGETING
PEOPLE HE DOESN'T LIKE.
IF HE THINKS THAT YOU ARE TOO
PRO-GUN, HE COULD REPORT YOU,
WHICH IS WHAT HE MIGHT DO,
BECAUSE THAT'S THE KIND OF
BUREAUCRAT HE HAS.
HE SAYS, YES, HE'S GOING TO TAKE
YOUR GUNS.
NO.
I THINK YOU'LL BE TAKING MY
ORDER AT STARBUCKS AT AN EL PASO
OUTLET.
BETO O'ROURKE'S QUEST, PURELY
EGOCENTRIC.
HE'S GOT NO WISDOM, NO
PERSUASIVE SKILLS.
HE HAS A JACK KEROUAC NOVEL IN
THE BACK OF HIS POCKET THAT HE
DOESN'T READ.
HE IS THE VERSION OF PHOEBE FROM
FRIENDS.
EVERY TIME HE SHOWS UP, YOU WERE
JUST WAITING FOR HER TO GET OFF
SCREEN.
EXACTLY.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Juan: ALL RIGHT.
GO, DANA, GO.
BUT THE PUBLIC, IN TERMS OF WHAT
THE POLLS SHOW, THE PUBLIC LIKES
RED FLAG LAWS, LIKES BACKGROUND
CHECKS, EVEN A HIGHER CAP ON
MAGAZINES AND ASSAULT WEAPONS.
REPUBLICANS AND NRA MEMBERS SAY
YES.
>> WHAT YOU ARE CITING AS THE
MAJORITY OF THE PUBLIC BEING
OPEN TO LEGISLATION MOVING
FORWARD.
THAT MAKES SENSE.
BETO O'ROURKE CAME UP WITH A
PLAN THAT WILL NOT WORK LEGALLY
OR FINANCIALLY FOR HIS OVERALL
DEFINITION OF --
RIGHT.
FOR HIS DEFINITION OF ASSAULT
WEAPONS.
FOR ME, IT'S NOT ABOUT OPENING
THE RIGHT WING TO ATTACK.
IT'S ABOUT RADICAL VERSUS
REASONABLE.
>> Juan: YOU THINK THAT THE
NRA IS REASONABLE?
>> 36% OF THE NRA MEMBERS ARE
DEMOCRATS.
>> Juan: I DON'T THINK THE NRA
LIKES IT.
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT THAT.
SPEAK I DON'T KNOW.
I FORGOT WHERE I WAS.
NO, IT'S OKAY.
TO ME, MAYOR PETE IS WASTING HIS
TIME.
HE'S ENGAGING WITH BETO'S
INFLAMMATORY RHETORIC.